if you only wished to be happy this
could be easily accomplished but we wish
to be happier than other people and this
is always difficult for We Believe
others are happier than they are monu
said this 300 years ago and we're still
working on this one so Tim Urban
resurfacing that famous quote really
highlights the asymmetry between what we
see of ourselves and what we see of
everyone else because humans are
comparative relative beings we don't
just judge what we are in isolation we
judge it as a part of the entire
hierarchy of society it's not just about
being in a situation it being good it's
about being in a better situation than
we were before and also a better one
than the people that were around and
also a better one than our parents were
in when they were our age this is a
intergenerational competition Theory
it's referred to as